i'm andy ricker i'm the chef and owner
of pakpak restaurant and i'm going to be
making a koetiokuagai i first had this
dish in bangkok in chinatown a section
of town called yawalad and this is a
really specific dish that as far as i
know originated in bangkok via china
it's typically served street side out of
a small stall down a little alley the
best places are like that and it's just
one of the most delicious comfort food
it's kind of i compare it to chicken and
dumplings it's probably the dish that i
go and get first when i first arrive in
bangkok if you want to talk about street
food in thailand
noodles are what basically personify
street food
and often
the vendor who makes it may have been
vending this one dish for generations
already my favorite place
in bangkok that makes this i believe
they're on to the second or third
generation of uh
one family that makes this particular
dish so the name of the dish is quite
okula
kotio noodle kula means to fry and gai
means chicken so we're cooking chicken
with noodles and we're frying it so it's
it really is the the name of the dish is
the same thing as the dish we're going
to add our seasoned egg mix right into
the center we're looking for is the
noodles to get a little bit brown on the
bottom you can see it's starting to
brown up a little bit and we're just
gonna flip the whole thing we're almost
making like a noodle cake but once we
finish frying it we're gonna break it up
a little bit when thai noodle vendors
make noodle dishes they season it so
that it tastes good but that it's not
extreme in any one way or another and
then it's expected that each person has
their own particular way they like to
eat things i like to sprinkle it with a
little bit of fish sauce i also like it
a little bit spicy so i'll use some dry
chili powder and then i also like it a
little bit sweet so i'm going to add a
little bit extra sugar each person has
their own particular way they like to
eat things
you want to cook another one of those
yeah let's do it i mean if you don't
mind yeah let's cook it oh yes